we finally got Dells new 2020 XPS 13 in
and I have to say that it's almost
perfect
in general I only have two main
complaints which I'll cover in just a
bit
Dell has been on a roll lately listening
to reviewers and improving issues we
complained about we really liked last
year's XPS 2 & 1 and I have to say that
this might just be better you might
think this one looks identical but
there's actually a surprising amount of
differences so if you want to see a
detailed comparison between the two make
sure that you're subscribed and have
notifications enabled in this review
we're going to look at basically
everything from build quality
performance speakers display quality and
much more but first a huge thanks to
Intel and microcell
her providing us with this Dell XPS
micro Center has 25 stores nationwide
with an impressive variety of
electronics from gaming VR computer
parts like processors graphics and
everything else needed to build a PC
they also have a huge variety of
desktops laptops in all the accessories
that you need not only that but they
also have highly trained staff and low
prices check out a local Micro Center
today to get your hands on a variety of
products before purchasing or use the
link below to view the 20/20 Dell XPS at
my Crescenta com one of the biggest
improvements is the 10 nanometer i7
isolate processor and new graphics which
makes huge leaps from the 2019 XPS the
main benefit is that it's much more
efficient so you're getting more
performance while using less power and
staying cooler than before our model
packs the four core 1.5 gigahertz ten
nanometer processor paired with g7
graphics as well as 16 gigabytes of
ultra-fast 3733 megahertz ram and 512
gigs of nvme SSD storage but before we
get into the really impressive
performance benchmarks let's talk about
the things that Dale has improved first
off even though the last XPS 13 was
super thin light and compact Dell
managed to make it even thinner and
lighter build quality is better than
it's ever been since they're using more
metal which results in a really
a chassis that feels premium and you can
tell that it's solid aluminum by looking
at the sides of the laptop around the
ports whereas it used to be plastic with
thin aluminum covers on the bottom dell
has added extra vents on the sides and
they've also redesigned some of the air
vents so they aren't as easily blocked
anymore
one of our complaints last year was the
hinge being too stiff but Dell has fixed
it and it's now a one-handed open on the
inside Dell chose to cover it with their
high quality carbon fiber composite
finish which protects from fingerprints
and it actually feels really nice on
your palm now looking at the display you
can see why this laptop is so compact
not only are the bezels incredibly thin
all around but the display is using a 16
by 10 aspect ratio just like the two on
one which adds more vertical space which
is really helpful on a 13-inch display
this was done by removing the Dell logo
on the bottom which I think makes for a
very clean look
you may remember older XPS 13 s had a
webcam by the keyboard which made
conferencing look awkward moving the
webcam to the top in 2018 fixed the
angle but at the same time we lost the
windows hello that made logging in so
quick this year we have it all a
fingerprint sensor built into the power
button a proper webcam angle and windows
hello support that we love thanks Dell
as far as the mic and webcam quality
it's about average display quality
itself is exceptional our model has
higher than 4k resolution and great
color accuracy and now 500 nits of
brightness which is really helpful in
bright environments and sets this laptop
apart from many others the keyboard is
no longer recessed into the casing and
basically covers the full width of the
laptop and it now looks incredibly clean
the keys themselves are now wider with
less space between them so they're
easier to accurately type on and they're
now click here as well but with less key
travel overall the keyboard is well
above average and most people will be
happy with it
the trackpad is also an improvement over
last year's model being slightly larger
and easier to click making this one of
the better track pads available in
Windows
speakers have been one of our major
complaints with Dell laptops but just
like with other things they've been
listening last year's XPS 13 had only
one watt speakers the new two-in-one
doubled that to 2 watts each
and this XPS gets two and a half watts
per speaker it's still not as loud as
the surface laptop three but at this
point they are loud enough and the sound
quality is above average being better
than the surface when I saw that this
thing got slimmer I immediately figured
that the SSD would be soldered just like
the two and one but I was thrilled to
see that it's user replaceable which is
impressive in a laptop so small if you
choose to pay $50 extra you get 512 gigs
like we did and I definitely would
suggest it since this isn't a low budget
SSD ours got about twenty six hundred
megabytes per second read and twenty two
hundred megabytes per second right it's
also packin some killer Wireless specs
like Bluetooth five and top the line
Wi-Fi six reception is a bit worse than
the surface laptop three in the toughest
part of my basement but still much
better than the new MacBook Air which
lacks Wi-Fi six asked for ports we got a
micro SD card slot and two full-speed
Thunderbolt 3 ports like the two and one
but we no longer have that extra
standard USB C port like last year now
let's get into performance benchmarks
where we'll compare our i7 to last
year's i7 in Geekbench five CPU tests
we're seeing about 30% higher scores
compared to last year which is
especially impressive since we know it's
more efficient than before when pushing
the new XPS to its limits and Cinebench
r20 is scored over 40% higher than the
previous best two gigahertz i7 as for
the graphics it's even more impressive
we went from fifty seven hundred to ten
thousand four hundred and twenty which
is over eighty percent faster graphics
performance since much more apps are now
using graphics acceleration this can
really help out now this definitely
isn't a gaming laptop but in firestrike
the g7 graphics destroyed last year's u
HD graphics so you should be able to get
away with some light gaming
finally the
life expect 9 to 10 hours of real-world
mixed-use if you get the 1080p model but
if you do have the 4k screen like we do
it's more like 5 to 6 hours which can be
a bummer the 4k screen is gorgeous
though which makes it a tough choice
personally I wish Dell went the way of
Microsoft and Apple and stopped making
us choose and just gave us a resolution
somewhere in between which can offer
both good battery life and a nice
viewing experience my second complaint
is the prices at the time of this video
the standard XPS 13 costs more than the
XPS 2 and one and more than some of the
competition but I know that Dell usually
runs discounts after a bit so once the
price is lower I would have no
hesitation recommending this laptop the
performance is excellent the build
quality is top-notch the keyboard and
trackpad are good speakers are now above
average
we now have Windows hello and an easily
swappable SSD and battery for future
proofing honestly even if it costs a bit
more if you need a top notch Windows
Ultrabook this one is almost perfect if
you enjoy this review make sure that's
how that like button and click the
circle above so you can see us compare
it to a 13-inch MacBook Pro thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]